je vais présenter très rapidement mais
mes invités alors nous avons dans cet
ordre Gael donc Audrin de mec et docteur
en droit de l'environnement
André sergent donc qui est agriculteur à
la pointe du Raz donc pour ceux qui ont
un peu de temps je vous invite d'aller
vers la pointe du rat vous verrez c'est
très beau et qui est le président de la
Chambre d'agriculture de Bretagne
je ne vous ferai pas l'injure de
présenter Marc feno qui est
vice-président de notre cher mouvement
et également ministre de l'Agriculture
à côté de moi Mot de Lelièvre qui est
présidente de l'UICN et Émilie
j'ai un doute sur le prénom Émilie mais
j'en ai un alors
qui est agricultrice et donc éleveuse de
bovins et qui développe un projet
qu'elle va nous expliquer tout à l'heure
alors je vais commencer par vous
Maud pour que vous nous donniez un petit
peu
voilà la table ronde s'appelle
souveraineté alimentaire et changement
climatique mais on souhaite aussi et
surtout
l'orienter sur une question qui est
parfois un angle mort du changement
climatique et de la transition
écologique c'est la question de la
biodiversité
on a un changement de climatique qui est
avérée plus personne ne le conteste mais
en même temps on a une extinction de
masse des espèces on dit que c'est la
sixième ou 7e je sais plus sixième 6e
pour le moment et qui est
pour le coup extrêmement important donc
on a une
perte de biodiversité et j'aimerais que
dans un premier temps vous nous dites un
petit peu quelles sont les conséquences
de cette pire perte de biosiversité et
ensuite nous enchaînerons sur sur les
débats
merci et merci de votre invitation donc
Louisienne dont vous avez sans doute
entendu parler à travers les listes
rouges qui sont les fameux baromètres de
disparition des espèces union
internationale de conservation de la
nature qui est une organisation
internationale qui travaille avant tout
sur la science avec des scientifiques
aussi bien dans des laboratoires comme
l'inrae l'Ifremer le Muséum d'Histoire
Naturelle des chercheurs mais aussi des
organisations non gouvernementales et
des structures détails qui a cette
particularité d'associer à la fois
l'état et les ONG pour prendre des
décisions qui lui donnent un côté un peu
atypique dans le monde des cops et des
négociations internationales aujourd'hui
le message clé c'est qu'on est face à
une situation qui est complexe avec
effectivement une accélération de la
disparition des espèces on parle de
sixième extinction simplement la
différence avec les précédentes c'est
que c'est pas lié à une catastrophe
majeure une météorite un changement
radical des températures c'est lié à
l'activité principalement de l'homme
industrialisation des forestations
surconsommation des ressources
naturelles et dans ce contexte on a une
accélération qui est mesurée par c'est
listes rouge mais par aussi d'autres
systèmes qui produit des conséquences
directes pour nous les humains
augmentation des zones changements
climatique important baisse de la
diversité alimentaire et puis des
conséquences sociales en chaîne
migration
guerre pour les ressources aujourd'hui
on travaille à l'ucenne sur l'idée qu'il
faut vraiment
s'adapter aux aléas et pouvoir mettre en
place une résilience une résilience dans
plusieurs domaines d'abord une
résilience sanitaire
sans effrayer tout le monde en ce samedi
matin on sait que 5 zones apparaissent
par an elles sont principalement liées à
la culture intensive non contrôlée dans
les pays du Sud à la déforestation au
stress des espèces on peut pas imaginer
qu'on va développer des vaccins pour
lutter contre toutes les zones on peut
pas les contrôler et il y a des épisodes
assez inquiétant comme le virus ni par
qui avait lieu en Malaisie ou en fait
des forestations intensives avec conduit
à ce que des chauves-souris
viennent les mettre des déjections sur
des membres qui étaient consommés par
des ports et heureusement la chaîne
alimentaire était assez contrôlée
l'importation était assez contrôlée il
avait le virus a pu être indiqué de
façon assez rapide mais on ne peut pas
continuer à avoir cette interaction
homme faune sauvage ou bétail fosse
sauvage non contrôlées et dont nous en
Europe on peut pas forcément mettre en
place toutes toutes les barrières et on
peut pas lutter contre toutes les formes
de pandémie deuxième question la
résilience climatique
la France comme d'autres pays et
aujourd'hui importent
peu importe 3,5 tonnes par exemple de
soja du soja qui était produit notamment
au Brésil et aux États-Unis
et qui aimait à la fois dans sa
production et sa consommation à des gaz
à effet de serre important on a un
poulet sur deux je crois monsieur le
ministre qui aujourd'hui a porté donc il
convient dans le cadre de cette
réflexion sur la résilience climatique
de se dire qu'on a nous en France un
capital qu'il faut reconquérir ce
capital l'assiette des consommateurs et
valoriser l'agriculture de qualité
résilience de la biodiversité parce
qu'effectivement avec 40 à 70% des
insectes qui disparaissent il y a
différentes causes la cause enchaîne du
réchauffement climatique
différentes externalités négatives on a
demain un vrai risque
de un vrai risque financier pour
l'agriculture française on sait que
c'est à peu près 15 milliards d'euros
qui est de production agricole qui sont
liées au bon état de santé des espèces
et ça c'est la Commission européenne qui
le dit c'est pas des associations écolog
et puis évidemment en chaîne
la résilience économique parce que
effectivement un monde en mauvaise santé
ce sont des milieux en mauvaise santé
sur lequel il va falloir compenser il y
a toujours un peu cette question mis
tout en réalité parce qu'on en a pas
tellement la certitude et des gens qui
pollinent à la main en Chine alors il y
a voilà je reviendrai pas ça fait un
sujet de polémique mais en tout cas
demain sans insecte sans pollinisateur
on peut pas remplacer cette action ce
service rendu par la nature à l'être
humain et on pourra pas imaginer des
processus industriels qui compenseront
toute la destruction de la nature alors
je on peut l'applaudir parce
qu'effectivement ça pose le débat et ça
ça pose des enjeux mais vous vous venez
de avec cette histoire de
d'être humain qui pollinise vous vous
venez de me faire une transition vers
vers le travail que vous faites alors
vous faites pas de la pollinisation mais
vous êtes agricultrice et vous êtes
éleveuse
je vais venir je vous avez un projet
vous allez nous l'expliquer vous avez un
beau badge qui s'appelle le bœuf éthique
vous allez nous expliquer mais avant je
vais juste vous faire un parallèle avec
ce que vous venez de dire vous parlez
des abeilles qui pollinisent et donc les
abeilles et les insectes qui structurent
le paysage je vais être un peu peut-être
iconoclaste mais se dire nous pouvons
pas nous dire est-ce que l'homme est
aussi un
animal qui structure le paysage et
est-ce que l'homme n'a pas structuré nos
paysages est-ce que si la nature est ce
qu'elle est ce n'est pas aussi grâce à
la part de l'homme
bonjour à tous alors merci de votre
invitation effectivement moi je
m'appelle Émilie Janin et je suis
paysanne alors j'aime bien dire paysanne
sans en avoir honte parce que dans le
mot paysanne il y a la notion de paysage
et donc effectivement
contrairement à
un certain nombre de courants de pensées
qu'on peut avoir de plus en plus dans
nos oreilles récemment
l'homme n'est pas à mettre en opposition
enfin selon moi comment je vis mon
métier de paysanne c'est au milieu de la
nature on n'est pas en opposition avec
la nature on travaille avec et c'est là
bien toute la difficulté de notre boulot
de paysan c'est à dire que on doit
travailler avec nos sols on doit
travailler avec la météo on doit
travailler avec les aléas qui sont plus
en plus nombreux on entend parler dans
la très très régulièrement maintenant
avec des épisodes climatiques qui sont
un peu extrêmes
et en fait effectivement on ne peut pas
dire juste condamné et dire l'homme est
forcément néfaste pour la nature on vit
en fait dans la nature on doit vivre
avec et on doit apprendre à trouver des
solutions pour vivre avec je vais
essayer de faire court parce qu'on est
très nombreux il y a tout le monde a
plein de choses à dire et donc moi donc
je suis élevéneuse alors je vous le dis
mais je commence vraiment des fois avoir
peur de le dire que je suis éleveuse
parce qu'on se fait attaquer taxer de
assassin etc et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc je suis éleveuse de vaches
charolaise en Bourgogne dans l'Auxois
entre plusieurs Auxois et Vito enfin
quand vous allez sur le 6 c'est avant
Beaune et à un moment donné j'ai eu
envie de porter un projet qui s'appelle
effectivement le bœuf éthique et qui a
visé à mettre en place un abattoir
mobile pour bovins et là aussi c'est
encore plus délicat de vous avouer que
du coup je suis devenue aussi abateuse
de bovins parce que là c'est encore pire
on est en des assassins et comment on en
vient quand on est éleveuse à porter un
projet d'abattoir mobile
c'est un sujet un peu glauque comme ça
on peut se dire l'abattage des animaux
mais en fait tout simplement parce que
si on est éleveur et que on doit et
c'est normal parce qu'il y a des normes
qui sont là pour protéger les
consommateurs
mettre en vente notre viande il faut
qu'elle puisse passer par des abattoirs
qui sont agréés par les services de
l'État et donc il faut des abattoirs or
on a depuis un certain nombre d'années
une disparition assez importante sur
tous les territoires des abattoirs et
quand les abattoirs disparaissent ça
veut dire qu'il y a des grandes
distances à parcourir pour nos animaux
et donc là on entend tout un tas de
d'associations animalistes qui nous
disent qu'on peut plus les transporter
ok on peut plus être transporté mais on
fait comment en fait concrètement si on
a plus rien sur place pour les abattre
et les transformer et et nous paysan en
fait si on n'a pas la possibilité
d'abattre nos animaux et de vendre leur
viande concrètement en fait on meurt on
n'a pas de revenus c'est donc uniquement
pour une question de vie ou de mort que
moi je me suis lancé en fait quelque
part dans cette projet de mettre en
place un abattoir mobile pour essayer de
créer une nouvelle filière pour que les
éleveurs retrouvent du sens à leur
métier un revenu et qu'on puisse
effectivement dire que oui on doit
abattre des animaux d'élevage mais on
peut le faire dans de bonnes conditions
en respectant les normes et en
respectant la dignité de nos
merci je crois qu'on peut l'applaudir
parce que c'est un beau projet et ça va
me permettre de rebondir et de passer la
parole à André André sergent donc tu es
le président de la Chambre d'Agriculture
bretonne on a beaucoup
piqué entendu de critiques sur le modèle
agricole breton
on a aussi entendu beaucoup d'âneries
sur le modèle agricole breton
certes nous avons parfois des
exploitations qui peuvent avoir un
impact fort et important sur sur les
l'écosystème et on pense évidemment au
sujet des algues vertes mais on va on va
pas aller sur ce sujet là par contre moi
j'aimerais que tu nous dises pourquoi
sur nos terres bretonnes
imaginez la fin de l'élevage et imaginez
la fin des vaches dans nos pâturages et
dans nos exploitations serait
néfaste pour l'environnement
ça paraît contradictoire mais c'est une
réalité je pense que tu peux nous
l'expliquer bien bonjour à tous et juste
me présenter un peu plus donc en fait je
suis un éleveur et un énergie culteur à
savoir que sur mon exploitation on a un
troupeau de 150 vaches laitières un
troupeau de truie donc de porc ne sera
engraisseur 300 m et depuis maintenant 8
ans on est aussi énergie culteur parce
que on a une installation de
méthanisation et également du
photovoltaïque voilà qui je suis et en
parallèle donc président de la chambre
de Bretagne alors sur
ta question là en fait je le dis très
clairement contrairement aux idées
reçues aujourd'hui dans notre
agriculture bretonne il n'y a pas un
modèle pour produire il y a une très
très grande diversité de façon de
produire aujourd'hui et c'est très bien
et nos jeunes qui s'installent ont
chacun individuellement un projet qui
est différent l'un de l'autre mais
globalement la force de notre
l'agriculture bretonne c'est bien le
système de polyculture élevage en lien
avec tout le nord Bretagne où on a
également toute une zone légumière qui
est assez importante alors maintenant
sur le sujet de l'élevage aujourd'hui
j'ai des chiffres et je sais que le
ministre à mes côtés les a également on
a des chiffres en France aussi
d'ailleurs qui montre et qui démontre le
recul de l'élevage sur nos territoires
et en Bretagne aussi et donc par rapport
à ça je pense qu'il est temps de trouver
les moyens de redonner l'envie aux
jeunes de faire de l'élevage mais comme
ça a été dit avec ma collègue là tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui
être éleveur à certains moments et
notamment nous en Bretagne dans
certaines productions et ben il faut pas
trop le dire il faut presque ce que se
cacher et donc c'est un vrai problème
alors que c'est chez nous c'est très
clair c'est l'élevage bovin qui façonne
nos paysages et donc quand on parle de
biodiversité
les éleveurs les agriculteurs aspirent
aussi comme vous à des temps libres
voilà il faut entendre ça et c'est pour
ça que nos jeunes vont leur donner la
possibilité de faire l'élevage et de
vivre dans un contexte économique un peu
plus favorable et dans un contexte
sociologique qui leur permet aussi
d'être entre guillemets comme tout le
monde donc voilà les points que je
voulais mettre en avant et alors après
par rapport à la biodiversité je crois
qu'il y a un chercheur qui est bien
connu c'est Jean-Louis Perrot de l'inrae
qui démontre très très bien que la
disparition de l'élevage sur nos
territoires ça va être catastrophique
quoi catastrophique j'ai juste un
exemple parce que ici ou là il y a dans
des petites zones en Bretagne où on a
déjà l'élevage qui est parti et
qu'est-ce qui se passe tous les
bas-fonds tous les zones humides les
fonds de vallées donc tout ça ça
s'enfiche qu'est-ce qui vient là-dedans
c'est le sanglier et dans les bonnes
terres on met des céréales c'est un
modèle effectivement que voilà notre
Bretagne voilà moi j'en veux pas voilà
donc à partir de là il faut trouver les
moyens de préserver l'élevage et puis
surtout ce dont d'ailleurs je suis fier
c'est que quand on nous a nommé à
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire mais je pense
que c'est bien parce que moi la
souveraineté alimentaire je me souviens
de mon père m'ont parlé c'est-à-dire
c'était juste après la guerre je me
disais on en parlera plus jamais de ça
ben si bah si faisons attention ça a été
cité aujourd'hui par exemple un poulet
sur deux qui est consommé en France
vient de l'extérieur et demain si on n'y
prend pas garde et ben notre pays notre
région pourrait être aussi très
dépendante des autres pour se nourrir et
moi je considère j'ai toujours considéré
et entendu aussi mon père le dire bah
oui l'alimentation c'est une arme donc
faisons attention merci André
pour pour bien pour bien expliquer et
avant de passer la parole à Gaëlle
peut-être pour un éclairage plus
du droit et des enjeux que nous avons le
justement la problématique que nous
avons ici en Bretagne et dans beaucoup
d'endroits c'est d'imaginer imaginons
plus de d'exploitation agricoles faisant
de l'élevage que se passe-t-il il faut
que ces terres servent et donc on va
avoir des agriculteurs qui vont faire
autre chose ils vont faire par exemple
sur notre territoire de la céréale quand
vous faites de la céréale
les talus et le bocage breton très vite
ça vous emmerde parce que vous avez
besoin de grands champs donc vous allez
couper et à raser les talus résultat des
courses vous allez avoir des des une
terre qui va s'appauvrir une terre qui
va favoriser les crues parce que quand
il y a pas de talus chez nous il y a pas
de régulation de l'eau et donc on a des
phénomènes de crue et nous allons avoir
une sorte de catastrophe
écologique du fait de la fin de
l'élevage il faut bien qu'on se prenne
conscience de ça alors oui nous devons
manger de la viande
produit localement mais imaginons que si
nous n'avons plus de viande produites
localement on aura encore des gens qui
vont continuer à manger de la viande et
nous allons avoir un système qui est un
système où on va importer de la viande
donc vraiment soyons très vigilants sur
les discours qui sont des discours
parfois un peu juste jusqu'au-boutiste
sur la question de l'élevage et du
bien-être animal parce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des solutions et
Émilie le dit pour pour avoir un
bien-être animal concilier le bien-être
animal et l'élevage et la nourriture par
la viande alors Gaëlle est-ce que avant
de de donner la parole au ministre qui
veut nous fera un premier
qui nous fera un premier peut-être
bilan d'étape de nos discussions avec
les enjeux au niveau du droit et au
niveau de l'environnement est-ce que
est-ce qu'on a des outils aujourd'hui
suffisants et et ce qu'il faut les
améliorer et surtout qu'elle parce que
vous êtes chercheuse quel est votre
vision aussi sur cette sur cette début
de discussion que nous avons merci
beaucoup alors le droit le droit c'est
un des moyens du politique finalement
c'est un des moyens d'action du
politique le politique détermine ce
qu'il veut faire et ensuite il passe par
le droit ou par d'autres moyens et je
reviendrai dessus ensuite pour agir
le droit de l'environnement est souvent
vécu par les acteurs assez négativement
quand on parle de droits de
l'environnement avec les acteurs souvent
ce qui nous revient c'est beaucoup de
contraintes qui s'accumulent des lois
qui changent des règlements qui changent
vite parfois des difficultés à s'adapter
ah oui quand un règlement quand des
seuils évoluent des normes évoluent un
cahier des charges évolue et bien pour
l'acteur ça demande une transition une
transition personnelle une transition
économique il faut qu'il se forme il
faut qu'il s'adapte et donc le problème
pour moi puisqu'il faut bien en venir à
ça c'est que la France sait faire des
normes l'Union européenne c'est faire
des normes par contre on ne sait pas les
enlever on ne sait pas si vous voulez
les remplacer et donc au lieu d'avoir
des normes qui effectivement évoluent
s'adapte à faire face à des situations
qui s'adaptent et le ski évolue on a des
normes qui s'accumulent et on le voit
l'inflation législative est un problème
majeur que ce soit en droit de
l'environnement mais en général aussi
et donc le juriste environnementaliste
face aux acteurs parfois est un petit
peu
démunis en porte-à-faux parce qu'on
parle pas forcément la même langue et on
n'a pas forcément les mêmes aspects et
qu'est-ce qui m'a marqué dans les
discours
qu'on a pu entendre c'est que le droit
n'est pas la seule solution
le droit peut faire beaucoup de choses
il peut interdire il peut permettre il
peut encadrer il le fait déjà très bien
mais quelque part il n'y a pas que ça je
vais prendre un exemple le grand hamster
d'Alsace qui est classé sur la liste
rouge de lui c'est le grand amster
d'Alsace est un rongeur très mignon
honnêtement c'est tout rayé c'est c'est
voilà c'est c'est très bien c'est très
beau et c'est un animal qui est très en
danger parce qu'il est très fragile et
très sensible au réchauffement
climatique et très sensible aussi à la
monoculture et on en revient au thème de
notre table ronde le grand amster
d'Alsace il a besoin de plusieurs
céréales pour vivre
or en Alsace et bien il y a une
transformation agricole évidemment et on
est plutôt passé sur certains années à
de la monoculture le grand amster
d'Alsace est aussi très sensible au
réchauffement climatique il n'a vraiment
pas de chance c'est une espèce un petit
peu effectivement fragile et aussi
sensible à la fragmentation de son
habitat notamment par l'urbanisation
le droit européen protège le grand
amster d'Alsace c'est une vraiment c'est
une protection extrêmement étendue sur
le principe
pourtant ça ne marchait pas et oui le
Grand Hamster était très protégé on
pouvait pas le détruire on ne pouvons
devait protéger son habitat
et pour autant les la quantité d'espèces
n'augmentez pas
ce qui s'est passé c'est que la région
Alsace a créé un plan d'action pour le
protéger et notamment en associant les
agriculteurs beaucoup d'études des
essais en laboratoire des essais en
animalerie avec des types d'alimentation
et au final qu'est-ce qu'ils ont détecté
déjà que le grand amster d'Alsace le
problème c'est que il a besoin de
couvert parce qu'il est très exposé au
prédateur en plus n'avait pas besoin de
ça et il sort l'été quand il y a la
moisson des blés et qu'il n'a plus de
couvert pour se protéger et donc vous
imaginez ce qui se passe et bien le
Grand Hamster se fait attraper par tous
ces prédateurs donc déjà première chose
ce que ce qu'on décidait de faire des
agriculteurs en lien avec les élus c'est
de développer des zones protégées où il
n'y a plus de monoculture où il y a de
la luzerne où il y a du blé etc et donc
l'alimentation est assurée
et d'autre part ça favorise l'état des
sols puisqu'on sait bien que la
motoculture est pas toujours très
efficace pour la bonne santé des sols et
pour leur protection d'autre part ils
ont créé des systèmes permettant de
garder un minimum de couverts et donc le
grain de l'Alsace lui peut désormais
circuler sans être en vue de tous ces
prédateurs c'est quand même un peu
embêtant
donc finalement là est-ce que c'est le
droit qui a permis quelque chose il a
certainement incité ou est-ce que c'est
finalement plutôt le volontarisme des
acteurs locaux en association avec les
agriculteurs en permettant de créer une
synergie entre les besoins de tous qui a
marché et certainement un peu les deux
et donc c'est pour ça que je disais que
le droit n'est qu'un des moyens du
politique il ne faut pas se focaliser
uniquement dessus parce que sinon je
pense que le grand hamster et bien il
serait vraiment dans la difficulté
actuellement bon il est toujours on
n'est pas non plus dans une situation
extrêmement favorable néanmoins en 2021
on a compté beaucoup plus de terriers
qu'il y en a jamais eu depuis des années
donc bonne nouvelle le Grand Hamster
n'est pas sauvé
et pourtant il est en meilleure santé et
je pense qu'on peut s'en satisfaire
merci merci Gaëlle pour cette
cette exemple qui qui alors j'ai regardé
avec Marc il est effectivement très
mignon le grand amster d'Alsace je vous
encourage ceux qui l'ont pas encore fait
sur leur téléphone voilà pour ce Google
mon ami allez regarder le grand hamster
d'Alsace il est très fatiguant que ça
d'ailleurs voilà alors Marc on a là
quand même des des enjeux importants
pour pour notre pays
on la France est un producteur agricole
historique nous avons pendant longtemps
nourri l'Europe et je pense qu'on a
cette cette chance de le faire mais on a
vu aussi que depuis quelques années les
chiffres étaient moins bons et que
pendant très longtemps la la balance
commerciale agricole qui était largement
positive pour la France ne l'est plus il
me semble sur certains chiffres ou
difficile on arrive à un équilibre alors
comment on imagine aujourd'hui répondre
à ces enjeux les enjeux du climat les
enjeux de la biodiversité et de la
qualité de nos paysages sachant qu'on
l'a dit et je crois que Émilie vous
l'avez bien résumé sans paysan pas de
paysage et d'ailleurs dans la nature
qu'est-ce qu'on aime c'est la nature ou
les paysages c'est une vraie question
peut-être qu'il faut qu'on se pose aussi
et qu'il faut qu'on se pose pour pour
avancer sur le sujet donc comment on
fait monsieur le ministre pour nourrir
les Français avec des aliments de
qualité des aliments sains et des
aliments qui préservent notre
environnement et peut-être même je vais
être audacieux qui a certains endroits
reconquières cette qualité et et le
grand hamster d'Alsace est un exemple on
a parfois la possibilité de reconquérir
des zones qui ont été abîmées par la
main humaine alors comment on fait
monsieur le ministre
je vais commencer par peut-être essayer
de poser le problème de la façon
suivante mais ça rejoint ce que tu viens
de dire c'est
la vérité le système en tout cas au
niveau français européen le système dans
lequel on vit est un système
profondément anthropisé c'est à dire
l'essentiel de ce qui fait nos paysages
et compris nos paysages naturels y
compris nos paysages forestiers c'est
des paysages et des écosystèmes qui sont
liés à ce qu'a fait l'homme
positivement ou négativement d'ailleurs
il y a très peu d'endroits en France
mais je parle sous l'oeil d'une experte
en tout cas mais il y a très peu
d'endroits en France on peut se dire
c'est l'état de nature ici il s'est
passé des choses pendant des siècles il
y a peut-être la Guyane mais c'est un
peu loin de l'Hexagone mais globalement
tous les espaces dans lesquels on vit
c'est des espaces qui sont le produit de
l'activité des êtres humains
et je parle de je pars de ça parce que
si on n'a pas cette conscience là on n'a
pas la conscience de ce qu'est notre
propre responsabilité me semble-t-il
et donc il faut qu'on réfléchisse les
choses avec l'idée que le système étant
et je ne vois pas avec la densité que
nous avons et la démographie que nous
avons l'idée qu'on puisse hors marge
revenir un état naturel
si grand que je suis pas sûr que ça
serait que ça soit pas l'élevage un peu
contre-productif donc on a un système
qui est sous la dépendance de notre
action quand elle est négative c'est
regrettable mais elle peut être positive
aussi et donc c'est aussi là-dessus
qu'il faut me semble-t-il travailler
deuxième élément le besoin de
biodiversité la vérité ça m'amènera à la
question de la souveraineté le besoin de
la biodiversité c'est un besoin pour les
écosystèmes évident
c'est un besoin
pour y compris les activités agricoles
parce que je pense que on voit bien
qu'un certain nombre de réponses qu'on a
devant nous mais le président de la
Chambre c'est mieux que moi encore c'est
une certaine des réponses qu'on peut
apporter c'est des réponses qui se
conduit des solutions par la nature les
systèmes de biocontrôle la place de la
haie on n'a pas parlé de la qualité
agronomique la qualité des sols qui est
un élément une grande partie de la vie
on la voit pas elle est en sous-sol
c'est un élément absolument fondamental
parce qu'on voit que l'agriculture qu'on
avait parfois développé depuis des
années parfois créé des problèmes sur la
nature des sols et leurs richesse et
leur capacité à produire donc c'est un
élément important pour la souveraineté
et un troisième élément quand même il y
a une question éthique qui est posée
dans cette affaire de biodiversité
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas se contenter
de dire que nous céderions aux
générations futures
une biodiversité encore plus dégradée
donc on a une responsabilité c'est une
question éthique quand même les
questions de la biosystification
économique c'est une question
écosystémique et c'est une question
éthique première élément deuxième
élément je vais essayer de pas être trop
long et one je te rassure
la vérité c'est je vais essayer de
l'éclairer par un ou deux sujets la
vérité c'est que tout ça est très
compliqué
quand je sais plus qui disait que la
moitié de l'élevage bovin non l'élevage
de volailles venait des frontières
extérieurs si vous faites quelque chose
simple en termes de souveraineté
alimentaire c'est qu'il faut refaire des
volailles en France c'est à dire qu'il
faut doubler le nombre de volailles en
France je n'ai pas le sentiment que ce
soit la comment dirais-je
la volonté exprimée par un certain
nombre en tout cas or on peut pas à la
fois dire il y a des projets des sujets
de déforestation importées il y a des
sujets de gaz à effet de serre importé
et pas se poser la question de quelle
est la part que nous prenons à ça c'est
à dire la part de reconquête ça me
permet au passage d'ailleurs de répondre
à quelque chose qui est parfois un objet
d'inquiétude chez les agriculteurs on
est globalement en tout cas on vient de
rouge sans doute en tendance longue et
lourde en diminution de consommation de
viande rouge mais il suffirait
de deux choses pour que les choses
soient supportables économiquement un
qu'on paye la viande au prix qui coûte
et deuxième sujet c'est de reconquérir
des marchés que nous avions perdu même
en diminution si on court plus vite en
reconquête intérieure ça n'a pas d'effet
forcément mauvais et j'en viens à
l'élevage pour finir en fait essayer de
d'éclairer là où c'est compliqué c'est
que à la vérité les systèmes qu'on
regarde les systèmes agroécologie sur
lequel beaucoup de gens travaillent et
qui est au fond la reprise de vieilles
pratiques mais mise au goût du jour
parce qu'on y intègre un autre élément
qui est la question du dérèglement
climatique c'est souvent des modèles qui
sont basés sur l'élevage
au-delà de ce que ça apporte en termes
de biodiversité quand vous regardez y
compris des modèles que tu critiques
c'est-à-dire les modèles de plaine
fertile
non je blague
c'est des modèles sur lequel une partie
des agriculteurs avaient de l'élevage
pourquoi parce qu'on peut pas à la fois
dire il faut qu'on lutte contre les
dérèglement climatique donc il faut
qu'on ait des fertilisants qui ne soit
pas issus
de la pétrochimie
et à moins que quelqu'un vienne nous
dire mais alors là faut qu'il faut qu'il
regarde l'histoire multimillénaire qu'on
peut faire de l'agriculture sans
fertilisant
alors ça c'est une théorie et donc pour
récupérer des fertilisants il y en a une
deuxième catégorie c'est les
fertilisants organiques et une grande
partie des fertilisants organiques qui
viennent de l'élevage
et dire le modèle qui devrait plutôt se
développer c'est en théorie en tout cas
c'est plutôt un modèle de polyculturelle
vache et donc on a besoin de l'élevage
au-delà de ce que vous avez dit tous sur
la question de la de la de ce que ça ce
que ça produit en termes de bio
diversité donc c'est cette complexité là
est immense alors après il faut qu'on
fasse de la hiérarchie moi je pense
si on veut tenir un modèle d'élevage une
fois que j'ai dit ça faut pas qu'on
vienne d'abord faut qu'on fasse de la
planification y compris pour les
éleveurs parce que il y a pas de chemin
si jamais tous les matins on change les
règles
c'est impossible parce qu'il faut que
les opérateurs s'organisent et dire tous
les deux ans je change les règles c'est
c'est à s'assurer d'une chose c'est qu'à
la fin on continuera à importer encore
plus
et ça c'est une question de souveraineté
mais c'est aucune question de
biodiversité donc ça c'est un élément
qui me paraît absolument central et
j'aurais finir pour pas être trop long
sur un sujet qui me les modes le sexe
qu'on en a parlé mais qui est un sujet
polémique
mais qui est un très beau symbole de
décontradictions du monde dans lequel on
vit c'est le sujet du loup
parce qu'elle avait alors franchement
note notre
ministre est quand même courageux parce
que ministre de l'Agriculture et
prononcer le mot loup en tu sais pas ce
que je le sors que je réserve
franchement quel courage non mais je le
dis parce que c'est très simple moi je
suis toujours je le fais devant les
agriculteurs j'ai toujours défendu la
question de la biodiversité et l'idée
quelqu'un me disait ça l'autre jour des
fois éradiquer le loup jamais vous me
trouverez sur le chemin là jamais parce
que je pense que ça fait partie d'une
biodiversité
qui est quand même le symbole de ce
qu'on arrive à reconquérir mais si on ne
comprend pas
que l'extension du loup
pose après des problèmes systémiques sur
un certain nombre de pratiques d'élevage
je pense au pastoralisme vous allez vous
heurter à deux choses d'abord une le
monde agricole le monde de l'élevage je
parle sous l'oeil d'un éleveur c'est le
monde de la lutte qui a lutté pendant
des années contre les prédateurs c'est à
dire que dans le même temps qu'on dit il
ne faut plus d'élevage à l'intérieur des
bâtiments on leur dit mettez-les dans
les à l'extérieur des bâtiments et à
l'extérieur des bâtiments je vous
soumets à la contrainte du loup qui est
un une peur millénaire
et donc si on n'arrive pas à trouver un
point d'équilibre
sur cette question là et c'est la
question pour moi des règles qu'on se
donne parfois le Grand Hamster étant en
danger c'est à quel moment on dit on a
on produit de l'interdiction et à quel
moment on dit désormais que l'espèce est
à statue je sais plus comment on dit
est un statue de préoccupation mineure
on va dire à ce moment-là on réinterroge
la question de la place du loup le lot
est en train de s'installer dans le
Massif central en Lozère en Aveyron dans
un système qui est complètement basé sur
l'élevage au vin avec des produits de
qualité qui sont le roquefort par
exemple
si on installe ça de manière durable
sans réguler je le dis très simplement
ça disparaîtra l'élevage parce que vous
pouvez pas dire à quelqu'un que son seul
horizons c'est tous les matins d'arriver
à ramasser des brebis et d'en être morte
et d'en être réduit à la remboursement
de la perte parce que vous n'êtes pas
éleveur pour nourrir des prédateurs et
donc c'est très je suis très attaché à
ce sujet là parce que c'est un sujet où
il faut qu'on tienne un équilibre que je
défends mais il y a un moment comme on
est dans un système anthropisé on peut
pas dire je veux de l'élevage extensif
parce que ça tient les paysages je veux
des loups il faut qu'il protège leur
loups il faut qu'il protège leur brebis
donc il faut des chiens pas tout mais
comme les chiens Patou eux-mêmes mordent
les randonneurs les randonneurs portent
plainte on est dans un système de zinzin
donc si on n'arrive pas à le poser
tranquillement
mais vous ne me verrez pas dire qu'il
faut pas défendre cette biodiversité là
aussi la question c'est le point
d'équilibre et si certains éléments
extrêmement important pour moi et c'est
ça va faire la transition justement avec
un une première question et un sujet qui
me semble important tu crois que chacun
le voit en parlant de polyculture en
parlant de notre rapport à la nature on
voit bien qu'il y a une question
d'équilibre alors première quand les
activités humaines il y a aussi un
besoin d'équilibre
économique et il y a une question que je
trouve intéressante c'est quelle est la
différence entre le coût de l'abattoir
mobile comparé à l'abattoir classique de
Quimperlé que tout le monde connaît ici
pour le consommateur et pour
l'agriculteur sachant que ça permettra
aussi de rebondir sur une vraie question
quand on parle de souveraineté
alimentaire c'est la vie de nos
territoires et le la vie des
agriculteurs comment aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs vivent et comment ils
vivent bien de leur travail sans être
obligé comme certains aujourd'hui à
avoir des des des vrais des tout
simplement des fins d'exploitation parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à dégager
suffisamment de comment dire de salaire
de revenus pour faire vivre eux et leur
famille alors la différence de prix
c'est combien madame au kilo là vous
vous me le faites à combien votre kilo
de romstacle très très dur de vous
répondre en fait tout simplement parce
qu'en fait ça fait un an qu'on a mis en
place la batteur mobile et que notre
exercice notre premier exercice
comptable n'est pas fini
et donc voilà et puis bon qu'on n'a
jamais vu non plus il y a peut-être des
chefs d'entreprise un peu dans la salle
j'imagine j'en sais rien mais on n'a
jamais vu une entreprise atteindre son
point zéro en première année quoi donc
clairement
si enfin comment dire il y a l'aspect
économique je pense que clairement on a
fait les frais de d'une expérimentation
avec des coûts importants etc et donc je
pense qu'on arrivera à arriver à un
équilibre à un moment donné
mais on aura besoin aussi d'un soutien
si vous aussi vous trouvez que c'est
important de trouver des des outils
différents pour s'adapter et apporter
des solutions d'abattage sur les
territoires qui commencent à en être
dépourvu
et lutter efficacement sur les
territoires sur la souveraineté
alimentaire ça veut dire que c'est aussi
des politiques publiques qui doivent
accompagner aussi des outils comme le
nôtre mais comme d'autres qu'il y a
partout je crois qu'il y a un projet
dans le Finistère on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec
avec André sergent parce
qu'effectivement l'enjeu de la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est à la fois
de la production et c'est à la fois
aussi les enjeux de transformation et là
je repense à la loi egali avec ses
incitations pour toutes les
collectivités locales à remettre
d'alimentation de qualité locale etc
pour l'éducation ne serait-ce qu'au goût
à la gastronomie des plus jeunes pour
faire cela il faut être doté d'industrie
d'autres types de découpes d'outils
transformation d'abattage pour pouvoir
répondre localement de façon
territorialisée à ces enjeux
d'alimentation parce que la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est s'attacher de pouvoir
être en mesure non seulement de produire
de transformer mais enfin en tout cas
d'apporter jusque dans les assiettes et
d'un point de vue local en rémunérant
tous les acteurs de la chaîne voilà
c'est ça c'est s'assurer que ces aspect
soif plein mais pas plein n'importe
comment et que effectivement en amont on
est effectivement eu voilà toute cette
chaîne là alors désolé je j'ai pas les
chiffres je peux pas encore tous les
inventer mais je sais que voilà c'est un
enjeu important si l'enjeu de demain
c'est de laisser une planète
vivable à nos enfants et une
alimentation qui lui permettent de
rester en bonne santé et bien ça ça doit
faire partie d'une politique et on a de
la chance parce qu'en fait c'est la
seule politique
agricole la politique agricole qui est
une politique européenne dotée d'un
certain nombre de fonds
merci alors sur sur le sujet de la
nature bon le vote titre c'est président
du Comité français de l'Union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec l'idée qu'on émet là que que les
agriculteurs sont une partie intégrante
de du levier pour avoir cette
conservation de la nature dans notre
pays est-ce qu'on est d'accord là-dessus
ou est-ce qu'on est complètement à côté
de la plaque pour vous qui êtes la
présidente de l'UCN je suis à président
du lycienne je suis aussi fille et
petite fille d'agriculteurs donc j'ai
quand même passé une partie de de mon
enfance dans les champs pas toujours
d'ailleurs de façon très
enthousiaste quand on a quand on est
jeune ado mais en tout cas c'est un
domaine que je connais bien le sujet
aujourd'hui et je pense que le sujet
principal est finalement le ministre ici
à travers ce sujet polémique du loup
mais on aurait pu en évoquer d'autres
c'est qu'il faut absolument faire faire
en sorte d'avoir d'arriver à établir des
consensus parce qu'en fait on vit quand
même sur la même planète avec les mêmes
ressources avec les mêmes objectifs
demain il y a plus d'agriculture s'il y
a pas de biodiversité s'il y a plus il y
a pas une bonne alimentation et on a
face à la crise on est aujourd'hui dans
on a vécu en un an quand même ce qui
pourrait être l'avenir la grippe aviaire
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie avec
la crise de l'Ukraine dont on sait pas
très bien où on est parti le gel le grès
la grêle la sécheresse les feux de forêt
on a eu un épisode en un an c'est
peut-être celui qui va se répéter dans
les 10 prochaines années avant c'était
des scénarios hypothétiques aujourd'hui
c'est des scénarios réels donc en fait
on peut pas construire des solutions
ensemble si on discute pas ensemble
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la question
des espèces protégées on obtient des
résultats que lorsqu'il y a concertation
il y a le rôle des scientifiques qui est
d'avoir des baromètres les listes rouges
on en a d'autres d'avoir des instances
de qui réunissent pas simplement des
écologistes mais des gens qui sont des
scientifiques des représentants des
agriculteurs des chasseurs qui sont
présents dans les mêmes instances et qui
discutent et ensuite de se mettre en
place des plans nationaux d'action alors
effectivement il faut du droit derrière
pour que tout ça s'applique mais en fait
il y a ça ne marche quand il y a des
plans nationaux d'action ça marche sur
les espèces comme le loup qui était
évoqué et je pense qu'on a pas réussi à
avoir le dialogue suffisant je pense que
le débat qu'on a aujourd'hui on aurait
pu l'avoir en 1997 on aurait pu l'avoir
au moment de la mise en place de la
Convention de Berne c'est répétitif et
on n'a jamais trouvé la solution
d'échange et les mesures
d'accompagnement quand on met en place
des mesures d'accompagnon il faut
investir on va sortir sort du domaine
terrestre et qu'on va dans le domaine de
la pêche qui est aussi un énorme sujet
complexe en matière d'alimentation on a
eu par exemple une disparition du ton
pendant longtemps qui était
classé en très grave danger sur les 7
l'espèce les plus consommées les plus
sécher et l'année dernière au moment où
la France a accueilli le Congrès
international de l'UCN la bonne nouvelle
dans la publication des listes rouges
c'est que sur ces 7 espèces 4 étaient
sorties de la zone de danger pas de
façon miraculeuse pour mais pourquoi
parce qu'il y a eu un travail fait avec
les structures de pêche la mise en place
de quota un travail réglementaire
l'interdiction de pêche à certaines
époques et en fait on a fait sortir ce
thon rouge aujourd'hui on aurait plus
dans les possibilités alimentaires et
puis on s'est aperçu aussi de mauvaises
pratiques qui étaient bon c'est plus
vrai sur la pêche mais qui était que
même dans les cantines de vos enfants
consommaient de la saumonette et puis en
fait c'était des petits requins enfin
voilà il y avait des un certain nombre
de choses qui étaient pas totalement
bien suivies donc il faut de la science
il faut du dialogue et il faut d'autres
modèles et c'est pour ça si on sort
juste du sujet loue du sujet bouquetin
ou de d'autres sujets dont je parlerai
pas de tout monsieur le ministre c'est
promis c'est que il faut qu'on ait une
nouvelle philosophie de la terre à une
philosophie de la terre c'est le modèle
qu'on essaie de nous développer en
proposition c'est à dire une agriculture
qui préserve les sols le ministre l'a
évoqué on arrête de labourer on la
bourre moins on expose la matière
organique du sol à l'air qui va se
dégrader et donc on a une meilleure
fonction du sol on a un maintien de la
biodiversité des micro-organismes donc
on améliore la fertilité du sol aussi on
utilise aussi moins d'un an on peut
avoir des prairies et de l'élevage donc
avoir du bien-être animal il faut ça
permet de réconcilier aussi les
différents domaines on réconciliera les
urbains des villes
qui ont une image théorique de
l'agriculture et qui ont une image aussi
théorique de la nature je peux vous
rassurer parce que j'ai je vois les
débats qui peuvent se passer dans un
certain nombre de grandes villes les
solutions qui sont proposées par les
gens qui pensent défendre la
biodiversité sont utopiques non on peut
pas fermer les eaux et libérer je pense
que vous seriez pas d'accord la panthère
des neiges dans les Vosges je pense que
ça créerait d'autres soucis que le loup
donc on peut y aller solutions qui
n'existent pas et qui existent de façon
théorique donc il faut un effet
cumulatif des prairies non labourées on
a moins besoin d'entrain dans un train
donc on a moins besoin aussi je pense de
d'antibiotiques pour les espèces et on a
aussi une meilleure condition de santé
pour les agriculteurs moi mon grand-père
il est mort un mois après sa retraite
d'un cancer des poumons et c'est sans
doute pas en se baladant dans la nature
qu'il avait attrapé c'est sans doute en
raison des produits chimiques c'était en
91 aujourd'hui le domaine a changé mais
il faut aussi se dire que dans la ce que
l'on doit préserver c'est les
agriculteurs comme premier ambassadeur
et comme premier travailleur qui peuvent
permettre de maintenir cette nature en
bonne santé merci en réalité
[Applaudissements]
avant de passer sur une deux questions
là qu'on va pouvoir lier qui sont aussi
intéressants qui sont très intéressantes
et en réalité il faut qu'on revoit
peut-être un peu la vision des quartiers
que l'on avait qui était maître et
possesseur de la nature et qu'on passe
peut-être à tuteur et protecteur de la
nature c'est une piste comme ça que je
vous que je vous mets au débat Marc et
et André egel il y a deux questions là
qui sont qui sont intéressantes parce
que il y en a une qui est presque qui
serait presque
quand on connaît un peu le mode la
réalité de l'agriculture qui serait
presque une
une question d'agribashing quoi parce
que l'élevage en plein air contribue à
la biodiversité ça en est tous d'accord
comment les éleveurs en élevage
intensifs alors moi je sais pas ce que
c'est l'élevage intensif chez nous parce
que 150 vaches c'est pas de l'élevage
intensif il faut le dire vers un modèle
concourant à cette biodiversité et que
fait le ministère pour combattre la
grippe
qu'est-ce que vous faites Marc féno pour
que les agriculteurs soient un peu moins
comment dire
bâcher notre société d'abord moi je suis
je suis ça rejoint ce qui a été dit à
l'instant sur moi je ne crois pas qu'on
fasse évoluer les systèmes contre les
gens
ça n'existe pas
[Musique]
pour préserver ce que vous avez décrit
sur le hamster c'est très intéressant
parce que la vérité on peut toujours
produire de l'interdiction et moi je
pense que parfois c'est nécessaire
d'ailleurs sur tel sauf que si des gens
ne se saisissent pas
eux-mêmes de la question disons en fait
je pense qu'il faut en faire un élément
d'appropriation c'est à dire que la
biodiversité devienne pour les gens une
fierté en tout cas la biodiversité qu'on
sera fier des vers de terre ça on aura
fait un grand pas mais prenons dans
l'ordre prenons ce qui est visible à
l'oeil moi je vais vous raconter une
sorte j'étais président de communauté de
communes et on avait décidé de prendre
un programme Natura 2000 dans la Beauce
qui n'était pas complètement rompu à
l'exercice de la biodiversité
et donc je fais une première réunion
avec des agriculteurs et un agriculteur
se lève il me dit mais ça veut dire
qu'on va plus pouvoir tuer les buzards
et je me lève et je lui dis mais vous
savez que ça fait 30 ans qu'il est
interdit de tuer les buza j'ai eu le
sentiment qu'on partait de loin
dans notre dialogue
mais à la fin je finis et à la fin les
types ils étaient un peu il venaient me
voir il me disait j'ai dit j'ai dit à
l'association environnementale qui avait
un Ibiza mais ne répète pas que j'ai dit
qu'il y avait un Ibiza il y avait une
espèce et en même temps je sentais qu'il
y avait une forme de fierté parce que je
leur avais dit vous avez parmi les
dernières populations de Buzard cendré
de buzarder roseaux et autres et ça
c'est un élément de votre patrimoine
c'est pas faites pas pour les autres
vous le faites pour vous et ça si on
n'arrive pas à faire ça
les agriculteurs ils sont sur le terrain
ils tiennent la terre et si on n'arrive
pas à les embarquer eux-mêmes et aller
convaincre eux-mêmes ce qu'ils sont pour
beaucoup d'entre mais c'est pas la même
chose de les convaincre par par le débat
le dialogue et la sensibilisation que
par la contrainte la si ce n'est que de
la contrainte ça ne marchera pas
deuxième élément
je suis même pas sûr que ça soit une
question parce que j'essaie de ne pas
nourrir la querelle urbain rurale nous
sommes dans une société qui globalement
n'a plus de lien à ce que sont les
processus naturels c'est même moi je
suis dans un village quand j'y arrive et
y retourner de 700 habitants
y compris les jeunes qui sont dans ce
village je suis pas sûr qu'ils savent ce
que c'est qu'un processus naturel
parce qu'ils vivent à la campagne mais
ils sont beaucoup plus influencés par
les réseaux sociaux les chaînes
d'information continue et autres que
parce que des gens qui leur transmettent
quand vous aviez une population agricole
ces gens-là vivaient à l'extérieur il
vivait au rythme des saisons mais nous
avons une vie y compris en rurale qui
est une vie plutôt dominante urbaine et
ça c'est et c'est pour ça que ça me
permet de répondre à la question et donc
le travail qu'on a à faire
c'est un travail devant les pour lutter
contre l'agribashing d'abord il y a des
trucs sur lesquels il faut passer des
je trouve qu'il y a des attitudes d'un
certain nombre de gens
le président de la chambre et vous
l'avez dit aussi enfin moi quand je vois
des gens qui sont insultés des
parallèles de fait entre
l'extermination de population
et les élevages ou les abattoirs d'abord
il faut qu'on mette un peu les gens en
droit et l'église au milieu du village
quand même
faut pas laisser passer ça parce que
c'est pas comparable ce n'est même pas
entendable en fait pour moi comme débat
quand vous êtes et quand vous êtes
éleveur et que vous avez nazi camp de
concentration sur votre élevage et moi
j'ai un problème vraiment de fond là
dessus deuxième élément vous avez dit
qu'on avait besoin de transformation
et on a besoin de salariés dans la
transformation c'est à dire qu'on a
besoin de gens qui qui est le métier
dont quel est l'enfant qui peut aller
dire aujourd'hui mon père tu sais pas ce
qu'il est il est découpeur dans un
abattoir
or on a besoin de cette chaîne là donc
il faut assumer ça et puis le quatrième
élément on a besoin d'expliquer ce qui
se passe des risques de biodiversité du
dérèglement climatique et comment il
fonctionne comment ça marche
il faut que le consommateur comprenne
que si vous changez de modèle ça ne sera
pas au Bacou faut même que les
oserai le mot les distributeurs le
comprennent ça serait encore mieux
mais je suis intéressé cette année du
débat qu'on a eu avec quelques enseignes
sans donner le nom
mais parfois dans les propriétaires
portent le nom de l'enseigne
j'arrive pas à voir
on était en début d'été il faut tuer la
loi égalé mais il faut revenir à la loi
du marché qui est la loi du marché est
une loi d'écrasement du monde agricole
on va pas se raconter d'histoires puis à
on veut bien comprendre et Gallim et
puis là ils comprennent que dans la
souveraineté alimentaire si on aurait
menerait pas il y aura pas les produits
dans les supermarchés et c'est pas les
agriculteurs ni les transformateurs
faudra aller voir c'est ceux qui n'ont
pas respecté un élément simple dans une
chaîne alimentaire vous payez tout le
monde j'étais intéressé que les mêmes
disent moi je suis prêt à faire payer le
lait 1 € le litre ben on aura déjà un
peu progressé mais tant que je vais vous
donner un autre exemple on la filière
avicole a beaucoup travaillé sur la fin
du broyage du poussin débat les
parlementaires sont plus ceux que
j'avais sous l'oeil ne sont plus là mais
que nous avions eu dans la série
j'envoie j'envoie deux au moins 3
qui à l'époque avait vécu dans les
gallimes la fin du broyage la castration
des poravides etc il y a un truc qui est
en train de se passer sur la filière du
coussin c'est que c'est que on a décidé
que du coup pour les œufs c'est la
grande distribution qui va le répercuter
dans le prix parce que le consommateur
s'il veut un modèle le modèle il a un
coup le modèle parce que sinon on y
arrivera vraiment pas donc il y a à la
fois ce que disait mot de levial je
pense qu'il y a une question d'embarquer
d'essayer de se poser des questions
tranquillement si on a plus
d'agriculture dans un certain nombre de
zones montagneuses ou moins montagneuse
c'est de l'embrouillement c'est
l'incendie à la terre et en terme de
biodiversité c'est un vrai sujet il faut
qu'on se pose la question sur les
questions forestières j'entends beaucoup
de gens qui disent qui rêvent de la
forêt primaire
non mais de retour un peu à la forêt
primaire et je comprends le moteur je
vois à quoi ça ça
c'est le pardon pour de revenir sur un
nom l'homme est un loup pour la nature
bon
c'est pas pour honorer le débat mais je
pense pas moi à la vérité je pense que
justement ce que tu dis producteur et
protecteur sans être paternaliste
d'ailleurs mais on a besoin de de
conscientiser comme ça parce que si on
n'est pas dans quelque chose qui se
régule dans un moment dérégulé
on aura un incendie de forêt je crois
que 10% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre du monde c'est lié à
sécheresse cycle de déforestation et
surtout d'incendie de forêt je vous
assure que les 70 000 hectares qui ont
brûlé c'est beaucoup plus de gaz à effet
de serre que bien des activités dont on
parle parfois à longueur de médias donc
on a besoin de travailler sur un
entretien parce que si jamais dans nos
territoires et l'agriculture il y a même
eu des feux ici en Bretagne si
l'agriculture ne tient pas son rôle
d'aménageurs et d'entretien de ce
paysage mais parce qu'il y a une
activité économique pas parce que c'est
juste vous viendrez entretenir le
paysage alors à ce moment là on est on a
devant nous des aggravements des
aggravations pardon de la situation et
donc ça c'est une vraie difficulté alors
il a quand même du talent notre ministre
parce qu'il a répondu à une des
questions qui était qui nous étaient
soumises
il y a quand même un là il y a une
question qui est intéressante sur
l'accès aux fonciers qui est
problématique pour les jeunes et qui ben
les jeunes qui veulent s'installer parce
que on voit bien à la dans notre
discussion que
la présence sur le territoire la
présence de l'homme dans la nature on a
besoin des ouvriers de la terre et de
ses ouvriers de la terre c'est de des
hommes et des femmes qui aujourd'hui par
l'agribbashing par les difficultés
économiques n'ont pas nécessairement
envie de s'installer alors comment on
fait pour s'installer et après moi
j'aurai une question à Gaëlle comme ça
elle a le temps de se préparer un petit
peu sur est-ce qu'il faudrait faire
évoluer notre cadre juridique par
rapport justement à à nos règles
d'urbanisme à nos règles de protection
de certains espaces on a on a une
volonté du président d'avoir des zones
des zones protégées supplémentaires
comment on articule tout ça mais la
question de comment on fait des paysans
sur nos terres comment on fait
alors juste avant de parler du foncier
je vais redire un mot sur ce qu'on
appelle nous l'élevage enfin ce qui est
écrit là aussi l'élevage intensif en
fait
ici en Bretagne on nous taxe d'avoir des
élevages intensifs juste un exemple un
élevage de porc en Bretagne c'est un
élevage moyen de 250 mères environ voilà
ce que c'est un élevage en Bretagne à
côté de ça je vais citer l'exemple en
Espagne c'est 2000 ou 3000 maires sur un
élevage donc voilà c'est pour ça que
entendez aussi que notre modèle
d'élevage en Bretagne et en France est
considéré comme l'un des modèles les
plus durables et je pense que c'est à
juste titre et le système d'exploitation
avec des capitaux familiaux que l'on a
en Bretagne c'est un système que je
défends à côté de ça le modèle intensif
voilà c'est toujours le voilà l'image
par contre soyons réalistes et je vous
le dis très clairement
on veut parler de souveraineté
alimentaire oui on doit aussi avoir des
élevages en espace confiné et en espace
confiné en tenant compte évidemment du
bien-être animal ça c'est voilà de
discute pas là-dessus et pourquoi je dis
ça parce que une première raison c'est
le volet sanitaire quand vous avez des
élevages qui sont en permanence dehors
en lien avec la faune sauvage on ne
maîtrise rien au niveau sanitaire soyez
conscient j'ai rien contre l'élevage
pleinaire bien au contraire il en faut
mais dire que demain on peut imaginer un
modèle d'élevage uniquement sur cette
base du plein air enfin c'est tout
simplement dire
c'est pas possible d'avoir cette
souveraineté alimentaire voilà je
voulais juste le préciser simplement
l'autre aspect sur le foncier
effectivement le foncier ben c'est la
base de tout notre agriculture et la
première chose sur le foncier c'est déjà
de le préserver je pense que un peu
partout en France et chez nous aussi en
Bretagne et ben l'artificialisation des
sols c'est un vrai sujet moi je trouve
qu'on en parle depuis déjà des années
plus de 10 ans qu'on parle de ce sujet
sauf que les chiffres que j'ai
démontrent toujours que l'on clignote
nos terres agricoles donc ça c'est un
premier vrai sujet et ensuite le foncier
quand il se libère comment on le
répartit entre nous nous les
agriculteurs donc là il y a des schémas
de structure il y a des saferme qui
priorisent les choses le foncier quoi
pour les jeunes agriculteurs et c'est
très bien le tout c'est de maintenir ces
outils en place pour justement donner
les priorités à nos jeunes qui viennent
dans l'agriculture
ça fait un peu la transition sur les
questions de droit sur les questions
d'urbanisme sur les questions de
peut-être d'espace à protéger d'espace à
classer différemment est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait des évolutions sur ce sujet
alors comme vous l'aurez compris je ne
suis pas pour rajouter à l'existant de
manière non contrôlée un juriste qui
veut pas faire de nouvelles règles c'est
c'est notable mais par contre je veux
que ce qui existe marche et c'est loin
d'être le cas c'est loin d'être le cas
c'est faux les juristes veulent
généralement pas du droit supplémentaire
c'est souvent les législateurs qui est
mon bien en faire du supplémentaire
effectivement il y a deux sujets qui me
paraissent importants aujourd'hui
d'abord le zéro artificialisation nette
ça c'est notre gouvernement qui le porte
et c'est une très très bonne nouvelle
zéro artificialisation nette ça veut pas
dire attention on arrête de tout
imperméabiliser notamment parce que
c'est pas possible il faut construire on
a besoin de construire dans les villes
oui il faut bien loger les gens c'est
important c'est un besoin primaire et la
deuxième chose c'est que il faut aussi
dans les zones agricoles construire des
hangars construire des logements pour
les agriculteurs et donc l'idée n'est
pas de ne pas artificialiser l'idée est
de dire pour un espace artificialisé on
désartificialise un autre espace
pourquoi c'est important parce que ça
préserve à la fois la nature et moi
protéger la nature pour protéger la
nature je suis pour je suis pour tout
simplement parce que c'est notre
patrimoine c'est notre pays il est beau
et il faut le conserver ça appartient à
tous
la deuxième chose c'est parce que les
terres ont des artifiés des artisans
vous avez compris
ces terres-là sont souvent aussi des
terres qui peuvent avoir des vocations
agricoles et si on préserve pas notre
foncier agricole qu'est-ce qu'on remet
en question et bien on remet en question
notre souveraineté alimentaire et ça
aujourd'hui dans le monde dans lequel
nous vivons ce n'est pas tolérable
préservons notre foncier et continuons à
porter le zéro artificialisation nette
alors c'est récent le réservoir
artificialisation nette on n'a pas une
grande tradition effectivement
l'objectif c'est d'enrayer ce grignotage
des terres agricoles qui a un véritable
problème et si on pouvait le rendre
beaucoup plus efficace dans les PLU être
beaucoup plus vigilant face
effectivement à certains à certaines
tentations qu'on peut comprendre
d'artificialiser parce que il faut
construire parce que les communes ont
besoin de trouver des espaces pour leur
lotissement parce qu'il y a une forte
pression on peut comprendre ça je crois
qu'il faut là beaucoup de fermeté de
dire non et je je pense aussi que la
concurrence entre les communes la
concurrence entre les métropoles pour
attirer le plus de personnes et donc ce
qui fait qu'à certains endroits on a
besoin de construire on s'étend et
d'autres à côté se vident ça c'est pas
un modèle durable donc ça c'est la
première chose être très ferme par
rapport à ça au 0 artificialisation
nette et rapidement la deuxième chose
les trames vertes et bleu je sais pas si
vous connaissez les traversées bleus ce
sont des corridors écologiques qui
protègent les déplacements des espèces
parce que sans protéger ses déplacements
effectivement c'est très compliqué pour
elle de se nourrir de se reproduire et
bien de la même manière dans les PLU de
la même manière dans les autorisations
et pareil en coordination avec les
agriculteurs protéger ses espaces de
déplacement protéger ses corridors et je
pense que déjà si on rend ces deux
instruments traversés bleus et zéro
artificialisation d'être efficace on
aura fait beaucoup
merci
on me je suis un peu le maître du temps
et on me dit que qu'il faut qu'on mais
non non mais attendez attendez
non mais alors justement alors voilà ce
compteur se compteur n'est pas compteur
ce compteur n'est pas bien et réglé et
il nous reste en réalité 5 minutes donc
voilà alors on a des faits scientifiques
effectivement d'un temps qui passe qui
n'est pas le faire relatif du temps du
retard inhérent à notre à notre
mouvement politique et comme moi je suis
très discipliné j'écoute ce que veut
dire la secrétaire notre brillante
secrétaire général
un petit mot de conclusion chacun sur ce
sujet
qui est un sujet vital pour tous parce
qu'on parle d'alimentation donc on parle
de notre vie et comme on l'a vu on parle
aussi de nos paysages et donc voilà on
est quand même dans un quelque chose de
de primordial pour pour l'activité
humaine et l'humain donc conclusion pas
simple mais conclusion avec peut-être
des pistes pour pour avancer alors je
vais peut-être commencer en reprenant la
dernière question qui est là
alors conclure par une question c'est
bien non mais je vais répondre très très
brièvement parce que c'est un vrai sujet
l'impact carbone et le lien avec le
climat sachez qu'aujourd'hui dans le
Finistère on a une ferme expérimentale
dans le centre du département à trévares
ou aujourd'hui on a un troupeau laitier
complètement bas carbone c'est quoi le
principe c'est de rester productif de
continuer à produire du lait et en ayant
aucun intrant extérieur sous-entendu
soja qui est intégré on sait le faire on
a des solutions et c'est ça que je
voulais dire
[Applaudissements]
difficile de conclure un sujet aussi
riche ce que je voudrais dire c'est ne
pensons pas toujours droit contraintes
pensons négociation compréhension
mutuelle écoute parce que c'est un enjeu
et c'est comme ça qu'on trouvera des
solutions
[Applaudissements]
moi je voulais vous dire qu'il y avait
un truc qui je venais de ma Bourgogne
hier soir quand je suis arrivée il y a
un truc qui m'a surpris c'est que tous
ceux que j'ai croisé ici avait la banane
vraiment vous aviez tous un sourire et
ça fait plaisir parce qu'en fait on a
des sujets hyper importants comme ça la
transition
écologique enfin ces enjeux climatiques
cette souveraineté alimentaire c'est
hyper important
et on a tendance à avoir des
informations qui sont souvent très
anxiogènes et on a tendance à trouver
nous très faiblement pourvu pour faire
face à tout ça à se dire qu'est-ce qu'on
va pouvoir faire à notre échelle très
peu etc et donc alors merci déjà pour
votre sourire parce que ça donne espoir
et je pense qu'en fait on a tous quelque
chose à jouer individuellement bien sûr
bon on a là en plus la chance d'avoir un
ministre qui moi je le découvre donc je
suis très contente aussi mignon
clemsters
non mais simplement pour dire que ça
donne la
simplement pour dire que ça donne la
pêche et qu'en fait je pense qu'en fait
on ne peut pas toujours tout attendre
des politiques même s'ils ont un grand
rôle à jouer je pense que les solutions
locales comme on l'a entendu et comme je
porte forcément j'emporterai pas une
enfin j'essaierai pas d'emporter une si
je croyais pas qu'on pouvait un rôle à
jouer et c'est en fait ensemble
politique gouvernants élu locaux et
porteur de projets et acteurs qu'on va y
arriver tous ensemble et avec le sourire
parce qu'en fait on doit aussi porter ce
sourire pour nos enfants et nos
générations bravo
un petit mot de conclusion alors
peut-être en conclusion moi j'ai
l'impression que je vais passer beaucoup
de temps avec Marc féno et les
prochaines années
pour se parler de loups de d'autres
espèces en tout cas je pense que si il
est le ministre de l'Agriculture qui
règle une partie de ces questions ce
sera le grand ministre des agriculture
du siècle à mon avis depuis tant qu'on
en parle voilà en tout cas la tâche est
grande moi
ce que je veux dire c'est que il faut
vraiment qu'on travaille je vais
reprendre les propos introductifs sur
l'alternative vous l'aviez évoqué la
question des solutions fondées sur la
nature on a aujourd'hui des pratiques
d'agrofondir historique qui permettent
de trouver une partie des solutions il
faut protéger les forêts notamment les
1% de vieilles forêts c'est pas il faut
pas mettre de la forêt primaire c'est
pas partout mais il est important de
vieilles forêt il faut les professer
protéger et la France qui est engagée et
le gouvernement s'y engagé il faut
trouver et mettre en place les
politiques qui permettent de lutter
contre la dégradation des sols
développer pratiques alternatives à
l'utilisation des pesticides c'est le
bien commun celui des agriculteurs celui
des éleveurs celui des consommateurs et
moi je pense que tout ça va se passer
dans le dialogue et dans
l'accompagnement parce qu'on fait pas de
transition et de grandes politiques de
changement sans moyens financiers donc
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut à court
terme savoir où on veut investir et pour
moi l'agriculture fait partie des
domaines où il faut investir pour
trouver des solutions durables merci
cher Marc à toi de conclure
[Applaudissements]
d'abord j'ai trouvé que on a éclairé par
plein de
petits zoom si je peux dire les sujets
qui sont qui sont de devant nous
je commencerai je reviens juste sur la
question des forêts je suis je suis moi
personnellement d'accord avec l'idée que
ce qui est encore de l'ordre du des
forêts primaires c'est pas forcément la
terminologie il faut les préserver je
mets en garde simplement sur une
tentation que nous pourrions avoir parce
que nous nous sentirions coupables y
compris pour des générations précédentes
de mettre sous cloche
parce que la miss sous-cloche c'est pour
moi un danger mortel y compris pour la
question de la biodiversité
pas pour c'est pas juste pour pour faire
plaisir c'est juste parce que je pense
que c'est une erreur de mettre ce cloche
deuxième sujet c'est que en fait les
en conclusion c'est que le vous disiez
ça a besoin de moyens
alors les moyens c'est pas compliqué
parce que c'est soit les impôts soit le
consommateur
donc il faut qu'on ait un débat parce
que c'est et c'est la même vous pouvez
toujours mettre un peu d'impôt sur une
vache à la fin c'est pas lavage qu'il a
paye
troisième chose je sais pas parce que
nous en sommes dans un moment de
souveraineté de sécurité alimentaire
qu'il faut le délier du sujet de la
préservation de la planète ce que je
pense que ça n'est pas délié c'est pas
l'un contre l'autre l'un ne marchera pas
sans l'autre et je le dis pas par effet
tribune je dis juste parce que ce que je
dis et au monde agricole et aux
associations que je peux avoir
l'occasion c'est l'un et l'autre
d'abord il faut pas être naïf comme l'a
dit le président de la Chambre
l'arme alimentation ça peut devenir une
arme c'était pour moi plutôt un objet de
paix de progrès entre les peuples
solidarité il y a quand même des gens
qui réutilisent et donc la naïveté qui
serait
de se livrer aux autres rien de très
près du coup que nous abordions nions
notre souveraineté oignon de règles que
nous fixerions et que nous n'imposerions
pas aux autres d'ailleurs c'est la
difficulté dans laquelle on s'est
retrouvé dans le monde agricoles les
gens finis juste ce que je vois Kawan
prépare ses affaires
j'aurais fait une
inaugurations
je suis d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
par tous c'est la nécessité du dialogue
et de la compréhension
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qui arrivait au
ministère et ça m'a parfois été reproché
j'ai dit que je souhaitais discuter avec
les associations et les organisations
non gouvernementales parce que c'est un
paquet global cette affaire là
mais il faut pas qu'on la règle par
Twitter
faut pas qu'on le règle sur les chaînes
d'infos continuent il faut pas qu'on le
règle seulement en justice
parce que si la seule façon de dialoguer
c'est le procès qu'on se fait
je pense que c'est une erreur et c'est
un défaut merci beaucoup